Tasha: 这怎么可能呢
Tasha: How is that possible?
Tasha: 就塞一半呗
Tasha: Just stuff it halfway.
其他人:藏这空调扇叶里
Others: Hide it in the air conditioner vents.
其他人：好在上面那个盖给你打开啊
Others: Open the cover on top for you.
Jake:藏完了
Alice:还有给你
Alice: Here's more for you.
Alice:还藏吗来
Alice: Still hiding? Come on.
其他人:来好
Others: Come on, sure.
其他人:发挥我的想象力
Others: Use your imagination.
Lucia: 哎呀镜子这会掉可恶
Lucia: Oh no, the mirror might fall, damn it.
其他人:这不是藏的是贴的
Others: That's not hiding, it's sticking.
其他人：哈哈哈那行找了也无所谓
Others: Hahaha, that's fine, finding it doesn't matter.
Jake:贴上去的
Jake: It's stuck on.
Alice:藏在这一个
Lucia: 希望他别掉到后面
Lucia: Hope it doesn't fall behind.
Lucia: 拿不出来了就行
Lucia: Can't get it out then.
Jake:哦这个还挺挺看到
Jake: Oh, this one's pretty visible.
Alice:真的没人往桌子底下这放一个吗
Alice: Really, no one hid one under the table?
Jake:挺容易看到的
Jake: Quite easy to see.
Lucia: 那就下面
Lucia: Then put it underneath.
Alice:可以拿个胶带这样反粘着
Alice: You can use tape to stick it reversely.
Jake:啊这个不好
Jake: Ah, that's not good.
Lucia: 哎我的美文纸到了
Lucia: Oh, my fancy paper arrived.
Jake:可以夹进去
Jake: You can clip it in.
Jake:这好夹了肯定有缝
Jake: It clips well, there must be a gap.
Alice:不太好夹吧
Alice: Not so easy to clip, right?
Jake:肯定很有缝吧
Jake: There must be a gap, right?
Jake:没有缝吧哈哈这么结实
Jake: No gap, haha, it's that sturdy.
Alice:没有
Alice: No
其他人:我好像我藏的地方藏的挺好
Others: I think I hid in a pretty good spot.
Shure: 我藏我肚子里一个
Shure: I hid one in my stomach.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Alice:我藏桌子底下一个啊
Alice: I hid one under the table.
Alice:就这样吧反正
Alice: Let's just go with that.
Shure: 藏到我裤子里一个
Shure: I hid one in my pants.
Lucia: 嗯那我就把这关上了
Lucia: Hmm, then I'll just close this.
Alice:OK了
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 我们光放大厅吗
Lucia: Should we only put it in the hall?
Lucia: 宿舍院子也可以放
Lucia: We can also put it in the dorm courtyard.
Alice:甜品台底下放一个
Alice: Place one under the dessert table.
Lucia: 这有这个大家要
Lucia: There's this thing everyone wants.
Lucia: 想粘也可以用它粘一下
Lucia: You can use it to stick if needed.
Jake:可以查人人影或者你你你
Jake: You can check everyone's shadow or you, you, you.
Lucia: 就是美纹纸可信
Lucia: It's masking tape, trustworthy.
Lucia: 今天要用的那个
Lucia: The one we need to use today.
Alice:可以给我一卷吗
Alice: Can you give me a roll?
Jake:能稍微稍微没那么难找一些
Jake: Make it a bit easier to find.
Lucia: 没问题
Lucia: No problem.
Alice:古希拉掌管交代的神
Alice: The god who oversees orders in Greek mythology.
Jake:也很难找这种
Jake: It's still hard to find this kind.
Lucia: 我需要掌管美纹纸的神
Lucia: I need the god who oversees masking tape.
Lucia: 哈哈要吗
Lucia: Haha, want it?
Jake:只是不信
Jake: Just don't believe it.
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀哎呦妈呀哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, hahaha.
Alice:没有仪式感一点
Alice: No sense of ceremony at all.
其他人:就把我藏在那个洗衣机上
Others: Just hide me on top of the washing machine.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
其他人:洗衣机上OK
Others: On the washing machine, okay.
Lucia: 不用谢哈哈
Lucia: Don't mention it, haha.
其他人:你说啊洗衣机上
Others: You said on the washing machine.
Lucia: 这个我应该也就用一卷
Lucia: I should only need one roll.
Lucia: 可能就差不多了
Lucia: That should be enough.
Lucia: 他是就是一买就是五卷
Lucia: He always buys five rolls at once.
Alice:哈哈哈找不着头
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 但是它很便宜
Lucia: But it's really cheap.
Lucia: 好像才8毛钱还是多少钱
Lucia: It's like 8 cents or something.
Lucia: 还是多少钱
其他人:看我估计长得像是在洗衣机上
Others: Look, I think I look like I'm on the washing machine.
Alice:一共吗还是一卷
Alice: Altogether or just one roll?
Lucia: 一共
Lucia: Altogether.
Alice:一共
Alice: Altogether.
其他人:其他人:然后我就然后就过去一拿就拿出来
Others: Then I just went and grabbed it.
Lucia: 是不是很神奇
Lucia: Isn't it amazing?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Katrina: 洗衣机上我藏了一个
Katrina: I hid one on the washing machine.
Lucia: 而且我们就剪短用一下
Lucia: And we just cut a bit to use it.
Lucia: 我觉得应该也是能用的了的
Lucia: I think it should be usable.
Jake:哪呢
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:洗衣机上
Jake: On the washing machine.
Lucia: 我找到了一大包
Lucia: I found a big bag.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 谜底就在谜面上
Shure: The answer is right on the surface.
其他人：我反正一拿就拿出来了
Others: Anyway, I just grabbed it.
Jake:这个这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Jake:卧槽找到你
Jake: Whoa, found you.
其他人:卧槽找到
Others: Whoa, found it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:你哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahaha.
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:这个很圆这个
Jake: This one is very round.
Shure: 这呢确实特别像那什么
Shure: This one really looks like that thing.
Lucia: 花瓶啊底下有一个呀好
Lucia: There's one under the vase, alright.
Alice:那藏底下能藏吗
Alice: Can it be hidden under the grass?
Shure: 藏过
Shure: I've hidden there before.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one?
Lucia: 草底下我藏了一个你有看到吗
Lucia: I hid one under the grass, did you see it?
Alice:这个藏过了吗
Alice: Has this one been hidden?
Shure: 不能
Shure: No.
Alice:没有哦看到了
Lucia: 没有哈哈绿色的
Lucia: No, haha, the green one.
Shure: 你要把我音响拆
Shure: Are you going to take apart my speaker?
Alice:看到了
Alice: I saw it.
Shure: 你咋不把我拆了呢
Shure: Why don't you just take me apart?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Lucia: 这还有
Lucia: There's more here.
Alice:这个底下有吗
Alice: Is there anything underneath this?
Lucia: 这个底下好像没有
Lucia: It doesn't seem like there's anything underneath.
Lucia: 但这音箱明天会放在这吗
Lucia: But will this speaker be here tomorrow?
Lucia: 有可能会放
Lucia: It might be placed here.
Jake:有可能会挪对
Jake: It might be moved, right.
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Alice:有意思
Alice: Interesting.
Jake:烤箱能烤吗
Jake: Can the oven bake?